like driving around all ashamed in this
Challenger that I thought was sick when
I first bought it and the Challenger
exploded who would even name a car after
that didn't the Challenger explode
really you know that yeah I was like a
NASA shuttle probably right around the
time you were born that [ __ ] blew up
killed a couple school teachers I think
in a think that a dog and a brother on
that thing even who was can you pull up
the crew let's see yeah that thing blew
up window blow up can you let me know
the date it was January 26 mm-hmm were
you born in 90 92 damn commanded by
Francis Scobie can we get a picture
looks click on my picture man down there
down so that's not an actual Dodge
Challenger that's a spaceship it's a
shuttle all the people died the puppy's
not there oh well hopefully it was Yin
yah what's that guy's name that puppy
that [ __ ] jiff palm Jeff on yeah yum
yum dude I'll [ __ ] jiff palm bruh
that little [ __ ]
yeah man I'll say this bring it Jeff
okay here Jeff I would like to say it
right now I've beef with Jim well
wouldn't that be such a great doggy
treat you guys come out with partner up
I got beef with Jeff palm I can smell a
collab coming yeah and this is it
you never seen this no I've seen this
this is the the very tragic though they
were not going to be able to get off it
what happened did like was that a live
announcer talking about it yeah he
didn't react
I don't think they don't know what's
going on okay cuz like if I'm watching
this yeah like that didn't sound like
what the live be another bright oh my
god
oh no he's like still talking about yeah
they're approaching sound so not home
ions it's like no they're not
well let's redo it go back a little bit
and we'll be the newscasters you mean
alright we heard Stennis Space Center
here yeah I got a mom Florida a very
exciting day for all of us here at CNN
getting to witness the Challenger now
launch of the challenge yeah it is
really getting up there huh yeah yeah I
think we're about sixty thousand
nautical miles not a mile a lot of
nautical miles right over there near
Coral Gables us passing over the stadium
right under now these spaceships the new
ones are actually built with this new
material that makes them so much more
durable oh god it's so much safer mm-hmm
and you know looks safe to me oh my
so Jehovah is this going in a couple
directions now I don't think that was I
don't think that's what was supposed to
happen oh it's coming back it seems like
maybe there no that's exactly what's
supposed to happen kids this is what's
supposed to happen they're coming back a
challenger there they are there's
somebody that's crazy man oh yeah I
remember we were in class and they
wheeled in a television and people
watched and you saw that live kids we're
all watching and everybody was excited
it was like a big day in America oh man
hey well rest in peace to that all those
people on the Challenger yeah Thank You
birdies
thank you for risking your lives it was
the first time I saw two women up there
some people said it's because the women
got in a fight in the shuttle and that's
why I blew up that's just a rumor well
thanks for watching that video right
there that
a beautiful little segment I think but
of course I'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you could check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe check gestures
curse scribe